non
[Musique]
le rendez vous est pris depuis trois ans
désormais au cabaret du bout des prix à
cerner la ville salle comble pour ce
dîner spectacle caritatif
un show au profit de l'association on
attend le combat d'un ange et les fonds
récoltés vont servir à financer les
thérapies suivi à barcelone par nathan
un petit garçon de 11 ans atteint d'une
maladie neurologique rare c'est pour
passe aussi un bon moment tous ensemble
et puis voilà c est déjà ça mais c'est
aussi pour récolter des fonds pour pour
nathan pour pouvoir financer les acteurs
apathiques en espagne voilà c'est ça se
déroule en espagne ces quatre heures de
stimulation par jour et dont trois
semaines ça coûte 5000 euros donc une
soirée comme celle ci finance quasiment
un stage
cette année de nouveaux artistes se sont
joints à la bande de nathan déjà très
nombreuses
[Applaudissements]
des chanteurs danseurs magicien
humoriste tous réunis pour cette soirée
qui s'est achevée tard dans la nuit ça
m'a beaucoup touché j'ai rencontré
l'enfant et ses parents vraiment des
gens géniaux très courageux et puis en
ce qui concerne la soirée super public
pour montrer aux gens que que ce cabaret
il n'est pas fait que pour faire du
spectacle il est là aussi pour la
solidarité donc on en profite
je trouve qu'il ya une belle énergie
autour de nathan et il faut garder cette
même énergie
donc moi chaque année je reviens avec
plaisir et je continuerai à le faire et
pour la première fois la soirée s'est
prolongée en week end inattendu le
lendemain avec un goûter spectacle
proposé aux familles